hey everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are reacting to
more
cyberpunk content this is night city
wire episode four
uh i have already seen this um but it
was under different circumstances i was
hosting the post show for
twitch twitch gaming uh which means that
you know you're kind of watching and
taking notes at the same time so this is
me actually getting to absorb it for the
first time
uh very excited full disclosure before
anyone starts watching i am
in the game so extremely biased where
it's concerned uh you know
don't buy it because i like it that is
not what i'm telling anyone to do here
um but yeah let's let's do it let's
watch the thing
i love these i'm a huge fan so cool to
have fun
where we talk about all things cyberpunk
2077
we're going to start today's episode by
giving you a look at just
some of the vehicles you might want to
procure during your time in night city
and having a chat to senior vehicle
artist paul who's going to give us a
in your video confirmation before we
take your job title
at the lengths the teams have gone to to
bring vehicles to life
we're also going to have news on an
exciting collaboration
then we're going to be talking about
fashion and styles in night city
before we recap the incredible talking
about it before
it's in our cyberpunk cosplay contest
we'll then wrap up today's episode with
some news about stadia
there is a lot to talk about so
let's get started hell yeah
[Music]
um yeah when i played it one of the
things that really stood out to me was
uh
[Music]
the styles literally night city
you need a chill ride to get around fast
and in cyberpunk 2077 there are tons of
cool vehicles to choose from
get this four liter engine six cylinder
goes from zero to a hundred and three
point two seconds you [ __ ] believe
that
pretty good it's so pretty
we've crafted every car and motorbike
with amazing attention to detail
i didn't
show me what you got
don't expect advanced tech or luxurious
materials here
i do like an old car yeah the size that
counts
i guess this class is mostly utility
vehicles
and clunkers made for every pocket hold
on hold on
it's a wreck that's me my damn wreck
well definitely no guy or girl mac
it's crazy if you need to impress i
didn't know they were gonna do that this
class alone
and then i watched it live and i watched
that one so that i could flip
it out on the line but that is not
matching dialogue
you can forget about the fight
with these wheels no expense has been
spared no frill ignored
their plush interiors decked out in all
the latest tech
while you get to sit back and enjoy the
ride
masterful engineering and practical
design trucks
and tanks for when you need power and
brute force
probably not so much my style nothing's
pretty cute though neat beast
my pride and joy and these monsters are
literally
come on i want to smell that tutu so
for the record we did confirm that there
isn't car customization she says perfect
for tuning but
whether they're different at the same
time
or just showing off in the streets with
these high-powered beasts
you will have i was told about that
oh yeah i like that if you need
speed and armor the hyper car class is
for you it means precise bodywork
built-in lidar arrays and really
expensive materials
imagine you're sitting on a pile of
eddies probably less than a thousand
people in the world can afford to air
indict
not your typical urban vehicle
[Music]
they will take you places you never
dreamed you'd go
oh and original vehicles are not all
you'll find in 2077.
we also found room on our roster for
some true
automotive icons something that i want
to talk about
let me pause this real quick
before we get to the next segment so
i've interviewed like a number of devs
about how they get cars to look
realistic in game
and um this isn't even related to
cyberpunk just in general um
one of the first interviews i ever did
was with um
someone who's working on whatsapp and
you can see it like
when the hood of that is probably not
going to be easy for me to find because
youtube scrubbing is not that great but
uh
developers will intentionally add
imperfections to cars to make them look
realistic because
if you see a car in a forza motorsport
or a gran turismo for example or like i
mean really any project cars any any of
them
um really uh and it doesn't have any
smudges or marks or you know
inconsistent pain or anything you will
identify it as not being real so they
intentionally
put a little scratch or a little smudge
or a little
discoloration somewhere so that uh it
looks more realistic which i just
thought was really interesting and that
is like consistent um across car
franchises which is
i don't know super cool i guess that's
how our brains work which you know that
just made me think of that because we
just saw it caught covered in scratches
so
let's continue
i already have it family paul thank you
so much for joining us
i think it's fair to say we've come a
really long way from roach in the
witcher
so that there's a lot to talk about yep
that's a lot to talk about what do you
want to talk about
let's start with the various classes of
different cars because in the video we
saw there were things like economy and
luxury vehicles
but can you tell us a bit more about
their kind of design philosophy
what does each kind of class offer when
people are driving them around night
city
absolutely uh depending on the variation
of the car
that you're either buying or stealing
depending on your flavor
yeah you'll notice that they don't just
look different but they'll also drive
different and fuel difference
if you're buying or stealing a nice
fancy looking sports color version
of a car you'll notice that it drives
you know faster sounds a little bit more
punchy and sportsy i think i drove two
cars for the record
that same car that's different solar
panels tied to the roof or some other
pipes that are but yeah popcorn
some other you know cyberpunk components
in your car
and uh well you know if it looks cheap
it probably drives cheap too
so it seems that not only do the cars uh
look good on the outside but there's an
awful lot of detail on the inside
as well things like the dashboard so can
you tell us more about that
because i know if you find a quadra type
66 in the city
it's gonna look totally different from
the quadra type 66
that the gang's driving out in the
badlands both outside
and inside yep definitely if you're
about to
steal a very nice high-end car for
example
when you get in you'll see the dashboard
light up nicely your seal dial indicator
is revving a little bit
that's pretty good that may not exist
for a junk version at all it may have
the dashboard ripped out completely
no matter what your flavor is you'll
you'll find something that suits your
needs
so what about racing then will it be
racing because i know people have been
asking
we did confirm that yes we're absolutely
going to have several races in the game
different locations if you know you're
going to be driving in the badlands
maybe bring a nomad car because it's
just built to driving in the badlands
but if you know you're going to be
racing again
just bring the hottest wheels you've got
because you're going to need all the
power you can get
no matter where you're racing though you
need to bring a gun because this is
night city and you never know what's
going to happen
okay so you talk about bringing cars
then let's talk about
like storing and calling cars because we
know people can steal them
but what if somebody's found a car and
they absolutely love this particular one
is there a way for players to kind of
build that collection and then how do
they
actually you know summon them well
uh summoning cars works pretty much the
same as you would summon roach in the
witchers like exactly
your transportation may or may not show
up on a roof somewhere there you go
but you know we're still working on
fixing some bugs here and there but yeah
if there's a car that you really really
like very much if you can't wait to own
a quadra or a type 66
you'll get a message from your fixer and
says hey you've got quadra for sale for
you you want to buy it
all you have to do is drive over pay the
money and you've got your very own
quadrant
not to mention that every single vehicle
that you buy
every single player vehicle is
absolutely unique in every way
it's got a unique interior unique
exterior paint job
you know it'll sound different but it'll
also handle different
so in the video sorry holly to cut you
off there
um i do also want to say another thing
that i believe we spoke to miles talked
about
um who was lovely by the way she really
liked him
uh every [ __ ] dab i've spoken to at cd
project right has been lovely but um
you i had this conversation maybe a
month ago that was
resurfaced this week in cyberpunk
it would take you a really long time to
collect every single vehicle but you can
in theory be a car collector that could
be something that you would do which
like i think is gonna be really cool
when the game comes out and we get to
see what
kind of different approaches people are
having to what they want to actually
accomplish in the world
but i believe they said that if you've
just stolen a car off the street you
don't automatically get to keep it which
is why this conversation is more about
um specifically like
you have to buy cars that you really
like that you really want to keep if you
just steal it temporarily you won't
immediately get to store it
um but yeah to the part about summoning
like roach it really is exactly like
that you just
it's it's on the d-pad i believe and
it'll just show up um or it'll be pinged
on the map so you know that it's nearby
and you can go find it
so we did mention that's your actual
space for a true automotive icon
uh do you want to reveal uh what that
actually is
of course the the car in question here
is
uh johnny silverhand's car and johnny
silverhand
is well he's a big rocker boy and he
needs some wheels to match
so we gave him a 911 porsche
from 1977 which means
in 2077 johnny's car is going to be
exactly 100 years
i love that well paul thank you so much
for your time today
personally i think i'm going to try and
balance being a super cool badass
mercenary and driving a my might
because i love that i think i could do
it right i could be cool
and in my mind definitely my mice
absolutely cool as long as you stay on
the road and not on the sidewalk
i'll try my very best we'll see
in past episodes we've said that music
plays a huge part in bringing night city
to life
but it's not just music our teams went
to
incredible lengths to recreate and
capture the sounds
that really bring these vehicles to life
i mean
they might have had some fun driving
them i love learning about it i'm pretty
sure that's just a perk of the job
i feel like every time that i've like
been to a studio or like even a preview
event or whatever and they talk about
sound design as someone who i guess i
studied it very briefly in university
was one of the subjects that i took for
six months but
outside of that i just think it's so
interesting the way that the stuff is
done like i think i might have mentioned
on the live stream even like the way
they do it for call of duty
it's crazy with the visuals and then we
wanted to like
attach a proper sound to the visual so
that you have
like a nice feeling or the nice vibe of
the the complete car and then we moved
on to uh
organizing the whole thing early on uh
we made the decision that we are going
to record on the racetracks
and then we are going to record cars in
movement we started cooperation with
tomac trophy who is like
very very well-known racing driver in
poland that's
really a nice sensation when you're
driving with a racing driver and then he
pushes the car to the limit
like you can feel the the g's with the
braking and
tight cornering and you can feel the car
actually like
bending the laws of physics we wanted to
record a broad spectrum of cars so
we started with the powerful muscle cars
and then we went to
uh more screaming we now love these
tunes v6s inline sixes and then we went
to v10s we wanted to grab the off-road
cars we of course
grabbed some drift cars just to have the
more aggression
we had to assemble a sound group or a
sound team that would
make the placing of the mics process
very very fast because we had
plenty of cars to do in uh we had the
team of mechanics
from a rally team and they helped us
immensely
what they've done is allowed us to put
the microphones into places that we
wouldn't be able to access
uh differently putting a mic right be
careful you have to be with us they
helped us to locate the places
usually place three microphones in the
engine bay three microphones
in the exhaust and two microphones in
the car cars are
very very complex in terms of sound and
uh
it's very difficult to get all the
necessary consoles i think it's so cool
to
have to make it sound believable but we
were trying to look for something that
would give us the character of the
[Music]
engineer
i did uh mention that i found the choice
of a porsche 911
which is the car i really liked it
strange for johnny silverhand actually
having the nowadays car but apparently
that is consistent
apparently that is consistent with
cyberpunk law um which
for the record i've actually been like
sort of avoiding so like
uh obviously um it's not a new ip this
is an ip that
that cd projekt red have uh adopted um
from
an old tabletop rpg and i've kind of
avoided learning too much
about cyberpunk law myself so i can
experience it fresh for the game and
then i feel like once that's happened i
will go
back and try to discover more of the
lore and like piece together a lot of
different things but i did want to give
a shout out to
um i believe her name is madqueen here
on youtube who's a youtuber who is like
goes very in-depth about cyberpunk laura
i'll leave a pin comment below but
uh yeah again i've avoided watching her
stuff
because i want to not know i guess
um but yeah that is worth noting i do
know that one tidbit that that is johnny
silverhand's existing car or he already
drove a porsche cause i was like would
he drive a porsche i don't know if
that's true but i suppose that he did
okay sorry back to the video six
sci-fi-ish sounding we wanted much more
organic much more down-to-earth
something that would that represent the
combustion engine
and on top of that we added small
elements like the futuristic horns
or like a futuristic ui of a car that
makes you feel like
you are in a car of a future and some
car might talk to you
other car might have leaps and bobs dots
i like that
futuristic vehicle
so many things advanced obviously like
you know human intervention is concerned
but
i think it would have been a little bit
too boring if every car was an electric
car obviously we want that in the room
we're very close to the department set
up in the lore
but i
from 1977. we record it on dyno in
control environment in
a chamber we could put mic in very
different places porsche 930
that we recorded is the only car really
that will be
at 9 30 is basically the real car in the
real world
that is the way that this particular 911
is known as
we recorded more than 40 vehicles not
often do we record so many vehicles
for a game that is not really a racing
game truth being told this was
the hardest part in my sound career and
i'm very very
proud of what we achieved with the sound
team this was something that we didn't
do before
so creating the designs uh creating the
technology behind the
how the sound behaves that's the best
thing actually i ever did in my
sound career
[Music]
it just occurred to me that i was in
this and i just remembered it and i'm
like a lot of
so let's take a look at another
collaboration this time
with johnny silverhand um i mean keanu
reeves
smell
[Music]
no you know it's not like deeper deeper
i'm guard hollinger i'm keanu reeves and
we're here as uh
representatives of arch motorcycle and
we're doing some opportunities
2077. archery
[Music]
arch motorcycle is a custom production
motorcycle company what's unique about
it is that
the motorcycles are built on a
production platform
but each one is designed to be able to
be personalized
for each customer
when uh cd projekt red approached me
about doing cyberpunk 2077
they also spoke about integrating they
were fans of the
or i guess people who worked at the
company were fans of arch motorcycle and
so
they broached the idea of creating kind
of perspective
specialized cyberpunk 2077
version of the arch motorcycle and i
thought that was a very fine idea
i wonder how interested in in the game
he is i don't know if kiana raised his
work in the game i haven't
have a motorcycle we've we've designed
and we've been developing
naturally i'm married 143 also in the
game my co-star keanu and i have not
discussed this particular particular was
was um a creative inspiration for the
designer so they sort of use that as a
basis
and went further so it has a totally
different crazy looking power plant
[Laughter]
today we're capturing sounds getting
some actual sounds of a power plant
drivetrain and characteristics of the
motorcycle which i'm sure they will
you know have play with and stuff but
the source will be pure
[Music]
i really wonder how effective those
particular microphones are in the
situation
sort of a racing engine in it compared
to our production motors
has a dual exhaust system and it sounds
pretty i don't know genuinely they could
be i don't know sounds good
i could definitely blindfolded tell that
that's the method 143 is sounding
motorcycle yeah
wait for this
nature of the role-playing aspect of the
game i think it'll be cool like to be on
a bike and hearing that
going to the city streets and getting
into the madness of mayhem
this is right it is a role-playing game
not a gta clone
role-playing game don't forget it people
keep forgetting it
as with all episodes of night city wire
if you're tuning in late or if you just
want to watch anything again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels soon
now it's time to talk about styles in
night city are you more kitsch
or neo-militarism
what is kitsch is that a thing is this a
thing people do
[Music]
but yeah the styles really stood out to
me when i played very very cool
welcome to the brief authoritative
history like all the games aren't
stylish
but this chapter is devoted to so-called
styles i don't know that i've seen a
game where the npc's deeply linked with
the history of the world
distinctly differently and aspect of
life in this city it's really diverse
you can find them everywhere in cars
clothes guns implants
they are your war paint as one of our
sponsors says
it matters not if you're dead as long as
you're doing it in style
i will also say it's on this girl
slicing them up like sashimi four visual
styles are evident
in the night city of 2075. maybe
with its own
function comes second looks are what
matter
[Music]
stanley here with you and we gotta so
colorful right
of dreams that's what i would want if i
get any augment get rid of my [ __ ]
ankles
broke out and entropism was born suck
vast and deep crises forced people to
find
who cares i love this town love it like
you might love a mother who popped you
out on the steps of an orphanage once
and now stops you to ask if you got a
smoke for her
[ __ ] them [ __ ] this job [ __ ] this city
deadly elegance without ostentation
corporate militaristic fashion mostly
seen in the wealthier parts of town
substance over style that's the motto
i'm so curious about what that was like
[Music]
[Applause]
brain dance stars business magnates
brain dance
corporate fortunes in a lot of papers
executives they abandoned the cold
deadly elegance of neo-militarism and
returned to the roots of kitsch
but gave it a fresh new look i think
this is my favorite
[ __ ] these hands sometimes seems like i
just brushed something in
sparks fly neo kitsch i like it
it's very extra which is not how i dress
but i like it
thank you for your attention we wish you
a very pleasant stay in our marvelous
metropolis
good luck and goodbye i appreciate it
nc's legends know where you'll find most
of them
the graveyard luckily matters not where
you're from
matter is not where you start
what matters here is the walk you walk
that looks like me but old
i already have it pre-ordered just
before this episode started you might
have tuned in early and seen
our cyberpunk cosplay contest finale but
just in case you've missed it we've
prepared a little summary for you
featuring our very talented
finalists in the cyberpunk cosplay
contest
we asked our very talented community to
cosplay a character from the game
based on the art screenshots videos
cosplay guides etc we thought regular
trophies weren't quite
cool enough so we decided that the top
three will receive
detailed props based on weapons from the
game
they have been specifically made for
this occasion and the winners can do
with them as they please
sell them to me the twelve best
cyberpunk
more of a collection of swords though
first place in the first
official cyberpunk 2077
cosplay contest are you ready to meet
them
these are really cool if you've not
already seen this they're
really cool
[Music]
so rad
[Music]
she would be what is it the gang of the
like militarized sex workers which is
like coolest book too
everyone with the name is um
that's so cool
now before we wrap up today's episode
there is one i don't know what they told
you
the widow's uh mio he was dumb dumbbells
but cyberpunk twenty-two
like six months coming to stadia and
today we can tell you that it is
arriving on november 19th
alongside other platforms and pre-orders
are starting
now is almost over
if you want just a little bit more then
stay tuned right here on the twitch
channel and join us
for our post show that's our host as
always don't forget that if you've
missed anything or if you just want to
watch again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels shortly and we'll be back with
night city wire episode 5
soon no actually there is
one more thing we're going to show you
welcome
to the diner
so what do you want supercar
big house you want to rule this city can
i get a house like that
well you ain't getting anywhere without
an upgrade you need a softer touch
stronger is fine because taking over
night city
ain't gonna be easy such an interesting
voice
[Applause]
i'm in cyberpunk 2077
available november 19th
all right i think that's everything
yeah um like i said i love these i love
watching them i think it's such a cool
way to like dole out information i guess
we're getting one more i don't know if
i'll be hosting that but maybe
um i continue to be extremely excited
about the game uh
and that's um pretty much it
so i guess i'll see you guys for the
next one
bye everyone